I actually took my family to Disneyland
recently to my kiddos how was your did
you have any meltdowns I didn't have one
milk no me neither rare very rare very
rare and it was it was raining the whole
time but we were just like we can think
about the rain or we can think about
Disneyland and we chose the ladder and
it was awesome it was also really
special because the my Frozen cast got
inducted into oh that's my husband y'all
are adorable I like him
um I'm keeping him my um Frozen cast and
I got uh this got inducted into like the
Disney Legend ceremony
I don't know but oh that's exciting you
get a pin okay and apparently the pin is
a very big deal and I'm I don't know
what it gets me yet
um all I'm really wondering is if it
will get me into Club 33. I I keep
hearing about this yeah this random Club
yes
no I it's random if you don't know no I
don't know that's true so it's like
super exclusive you gotta pay like dues
to it which I'm not gonna do but I'm
gonna walk to the front and go
with my pen with my Legend with my
little pin apparently it's like yeah you
pay like yearly and then it's like a
super fancy beautiful restaurant like in
the middle of Disney that you can go eat
and I also think it's the only place
that serves alcohol oh Disney okay see
alcohol I I don't know if that's my kind
of either I have kids that won't do they
don't do so great and fancy yeah don't
bring your kids together yeah but like
put them at like going there and then
we'll go to Pub 33. yeah of course
that's where we have to go I'm like I
don't think I want to bring my children
in that environment for other people's
sake
um and Dax I heard becoming you don't
let your kids drink dude nope oh that's
not true so no I just mean that's not
true in the sense when she was a baby
she actually I was I was in Scotland I
think and she it was an Ireland or
Scotland I can't remember where we were
and and she grabbed my my wine and she
she grabbed my wife as a baby as a baby
and we were both sitting in my ex and I
was like oh and I was like champagne I
don't drink champagne that's why it was
left on the table because I don't drink
it and somebody bought it for me nice
she grabbed the champagne and took a sip
as a baby
only a tiny bit don't take my children
away like it was a it was a sip and I
went what and I was like yeah it was my
kids have ordered non-alcoholic beers at
restaurants like a buck which sounds
insane if you don't know because context
is important we've learned that over the
last few years yeah so like my husband
and I when we walked the babies at night
in our neighborhood when my daughter was
really little he is a recovering addict
but he likes non-alcoholic beer so he
pop one open he'd have her on his chest
and we'd walk and like look at the
sunset so as a baby she was like pawing
at it and sometimes she would like suck
on the rim of it so I think it feels to
her like something special something
Daddy's family and we've been at rest
alcohol there's no alcohol in it so
we've been at restaurants where she said
do you have anything do you have any
non-alcoholic beer and I'm like maybe
ever home
it's so amazing when in your own family
you're like this is normal but then you
go outside and you're like so that maybe
doesn't track as healthy right um but
then I'm also sort of like you can judge
me if you want I'm not doing anything
wrong like that's your problem yeah
that's true yep yep that's on you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]